yo man bootleg podcast special guest
guest rather
hell rel jr writer yeah 40 cal
yes sir
yo man welcome to the show fellas well
welcome back
jr you know
two-time guest hell rel 40 cal welcome
um
how first of all how's everybody doing
tom guys three times
oh yeah okay
oh yeah cause you was on in uh at mean
head yeah so you did the radio station
and you came on the yeah body that with
y'all yes you did yes you did man
um well how's everybody doing first last
great blast
everybody's good um
what was it 2018 you guys dropped the
project together or was it 2019. 2018.
so that was 2018.
what is like you guys are all in la here
together for a reason what is going on
is there going to be some new music yeah
we
cooking up we working a whole lot of
stuff going on a whole lot of stuff got
a new new record called history
that's that's crazy produced by uh
but um yeah and we shooting a video in
miami coming soon so we working there it
is hey so i gotta before we get we just
gotta what's everyone's thoughts on what
happened in verses
it was a dope show it was amazing yeah
it was it was just historical though
you were in the building right was
everyone there
yeah we actually uh we actually was
there early we had walked out shout outs
to michael hunter shout out to my mother
walked out uh the main event that night
at the boxing match which was before the
verses right right right right so yeah
we was there
was there any like a lot of outside with
my ring high obviously a lot of dip set
fans were uh disappointed to not see you
guys maybe make an appearance yeah i was
disappointed i wanted to be on the stage
yeah i mean there was a lot of people on
stage you would think like you know what
what what were you like was there any
discussion of that or was that ever
something that was discussed or i was
supposed to make it happen as far as
like uh we were supposed to all yeah be
there you know from my understanding
you know what i mean what do you think
happened
um i don't know
you never know it's like when it kind of
especially when it kind of business like
when money gets involved in certain
things not that i'm saying that that's
that was the cause right but you know i
never got to reach back a quarterback so
i went ahead and um you know
did what we did you know man had an
opportunity with
to walk out uh at the fight with trilla
and she got on my truck so yeah
was there any uh what about with you
well like was there any conversation
with anybody you know about because i
remember watching the battle and you
popping up on the on the screen like man
rails there why is he not on state what
the [ __ ] is going on like i was actually
i was like he said he was ringside so we
we just we came to um walked the fight
out
and
we was about to leave and i asked jrd
you want to stay for the verses well
what's interesting about all three of
you guys is like i feel like out of all
the major like rap crews in hip-hop like
when we think of like wu-tang clan like
really the only outsider of the original
nine that was ever considered a real
wu-tang member was cappadon right right
everybody else is like affiliates right
right right you guys were all dipset
like we know that you know what i'm
saying no we know that
and so that's why it just to me like it
is too because they started out as jim
freaky ziki jewels and cam right as the
diplomats
when we came along it was dipset
so when people screamed dip said
that's us too
you know
how cause perfectly sad the last album
you guys dropped you dropped it the same
day as the dip set project
which was which was nice and uh
petty you know what i'm saying
hello petty you're obviously strategic
opportunistic and strategic no you know
it's just it was smart because you know
everybody all these different yeah
and some might argue you guys almost
better
oh that's work you know what i'm saying
that's dope but um
that's props no but it was a great day
for dipsy fans great day for those of
you guys
yeah because because we got both of
those projects um yeah the fans got a
chance to hear from everybody yeah but i
think that like there's like a feeling
that like there's like a disconnect
between you guys and the main guys of
the crew is that is that something
that's factual
as far as like as far as what like i
mean like like are you like how's your
relation how are your guys's
relationships with jim with joelle i'm
okay i'm cool with everybody i speak to
jim you know we dm each other here and
there you know i mean i spoke to him as
far as the verses you know i don't
really want to go into detail because
it's really it's like irrelevant you
know i mean at this point but
um
i'm cool
with nobody
yeah people think that we because we
don't do business no more that you know
it's it's some problems bad blood but
it's not like everybody's professional
like i reached out to to be on right to
make it happen so we can all be on the
stage because i felt like it was it
would be a dope thing
to see
you know i mean it would have been dope
what do you guys think
was the strategic error in the versus
performance
who's playing i mean on dip sets behalf
because obviously the locks won
just says from a hip-hop fan perspective
chemistry
chemistry i would say like preparation
and um
you know the right records and um
you know just really studying
your opponent because they didn't really
i don't think they took it you know they
they getting paid for it like they can
i'm pretty sure they get a nice bag for
it you get what i'm saying so
yeah i think the money kind of created a
cushion
and it's like some some people are
coming into it's verses so versus was
always the thing where you you're
celebrated you know what i mean and it's
not more like a battle this is more like
it's new york
it's the garden at the at the gardens
that's the garden
you get what i'm saying and you know
yeah
yeah i think preparation is what because
i felt like if cam would have had some
pick some different records as far as
like even freestyle mm-hmm what come on
yeah i don't feel like he dig dug in his
bag like he could have yeah i could have
went stupid the catalog is stupid the
mixtape the mixtapes i could have jumped
up there and told them like do this like
yo do this this this
what what do you what would you have
like what do you think he didn't perform
that you would have had them perform
shake
um nah not even just recognizable
uh like even his verse on ben from tv
mm-hmm yeah that's what's crazy is they
did that and i was like wait a minute
from tv part two verse
and got everybody out of there he could
have did that's me like and kiss that in
the interview he was like
certain certain records he didn't play
so i don't really feel like you know i
don't know but
my bad so to answer your question kev i
feel like um like best out would have
been like a dope song and the irony is
um we you know we walked the fighter out
to that record you know before he and he
won you know i'm saying so and the irony
of that also being best out is the same
record from um the fight night game
people used to play back in the day so
you know this
i guess that's starting to be like the
the symbolic record of fighters now you
know what i'm saying like you know come
out the best style you're gonna get you
know
something good there is some irony that
no matter what you guys did end up
performing in the building the same
night how ironic right that [ __ ] is kind
of wild to think about but there was a
fight prior it's gone you guys it's gone
and we was ranked i mean i went
backstage and all that i went to the
dip set like uh dresser room yeah he
went backstage uh yeah shout out to
everybody that's behind the scenes we
you know we um you know deb said in
everybody but we
we
began as a family so we know everybody
from you know the the guys from the
drive the truck to the to the guys that
hold people down yeah they're all family
so so
um
what's everyone doing obviously besides
coming together and working together
what's individually what's everyone
working obviously you just put a project
out loud was it last year right oh yeah
yeah probably like eight months ago yeah
um what's everyone working on i'm fresh
off the golden triangle i just put that
out june 10th
so you got new music out
just put out an ep june 10th it's doing
pretty good
uh just put out another record caller
really [ __ ] i ever wrote off of golden
triangle part two
that's about to drop
uh
any day now okay
so what about you 40
um to be honest i had stopped for a
minute because i was going through
something personal um but the last time
i was active i was doing um battle rap
because i was getting paid a bag for
that shout out to rbe
um and um smack as well and um
and i started my own like little um
battle thing and i'm it's a seed that's
growing called wrgb shout out to them
and um it's a place where
local talent can come um do zoom and
battle for money
for people to battle so that's just like
um
on zoom yeah on the zoom you can um if
if anybody interested on my instagram is
it's 40 cal you can dm me whatever and
if you nice we we it's like meta
premeditated battles like you'll know
who you're battling and you know we pay
money for that but that's just like
something little i do wrgb so right now
you feel like you're back like your
head's back in the game as far as you
know um
just just getting back on on your rap
[ __ ] yo to be honest um i think jr and
he'll rail for that
because um um
i ain't want to rap
i'm i'm i'm literally i'll be in the
street sometime right right to be honest
sorry about that oh good man um i'll be
like i really like i don't i just be
trying to make money doing whatever
right
it took a it took like a long talk with
jr being in the
studio with hellrail the energy be like
yo you know what this what i love this
is what i grew this what i did for the
past 15 17 years
so
when you bring it back to that you know
i feel like
that that's the motivation i mean that's
why you do it right and originally y'all
love this [ __ ] but i'm saying we both
share the same kind of like story
because we both had tragic events in our
lives i lost my mother my father and my
grandmother all within
the same year
that's a rough year man
and i still got all my marbles yeah yeah
i mean you know
what's the famous saying he ain't been
the same since his mother died right
right
mother father and grandmother did that
take you a while to get over that as
well i just snapped out of depression
after four years because of jail right
now
wow he's supposed to love him
let's get some more millions together i
say you're right
yo cause i mean he he's down playing but
he he never stopped doing music like
this is what he does [ __ ] like jesus you
tell me about like i'll be like he'd be
like yo you ain't getting your ass cap
or you're bmi from the this and that and
you know the labels oh you might i'd be
like
i ain't sharp as i know you know i'm
saying he'd be like well i just made
five figures but it says
like then i feel crazy like so with all
that being said
this is what he does so him being like
the foundation of
me and hell real motivation that's what
that's what makes us the team kind of
like you guys are like
you guys are all kind of in the same
position of the crew as far as
you know it's like a brotherhood almost
like y'all kind of grew up together in
the rap game pretty much you know i mean
no matter what there's going to be some
association
each other before we add deals that's
crazy yeah
so
so yeah we knew we all knew each other
yeah but yeah
yeah but yeah yeah yeah but but i knew
him before i met cam
i met jay y'all at the radio station to
be honest
it was high 97 yeah yeah
no we and
at the studio
nah that was the first date that was a
hot 97.
and then we went to the studio i met you
at head factory
so long ago
you know what i think you know why i
think different things
yeah we go through stuff like this right
because cam is the type he to um he
would hype it up he would say um yo
jaya's at the radio
you know you heard how he do you better
better deliver at this time hellrail i
think was locked up okay so i'm like
you know he put the pressure on so i
felt like i heard about jr i felt like
that time and i knew i knew how he does
like
you know y'all gonna hear the freestyle
that we did and yeah it's crazy like you
know what i'm saying
jr
so they
talk about pressure hot 97 and whatever
the case may be i i feel like i had to
put on
legendary legendary you y'all can google
that
i think that's the day but he said it's
a day like hit factory i think it was
before
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying oh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kevin checkout save 20 it's crazy
because like um the essence of like why
we all love hip hop music
is really missing on a commercial level
right now right
and i think that what was dope about
the versus battle was it it exposed why
we all love this [ __ ] to a whole new
generation because right now i mean
obviously kendrick is crazy cole's crazy
drake is a name i'm gonna keep it real
with you versus even though i wasn't on
stage made a lot of kids that
was
probably five or six seven years old
when my first album came out
went back and listened to my yeah that's
what i'm saying like and say yo hell bro
you were [ __ ] dope i didn't i'm like
wow this [ __ ] well just that essence i
feel like it's not saying it was dope
that that people went back and
appreciate the work that i put in
[ __ ] 20 years but i just think like
you know you know shout out to the
griselda crew shout out freddie gibbs
shout out like 38 special there's
obviously amazing mc's that are doing
[ __ ] the way we love it and no
disrespect we shout out to them but we
said that i was watching that [ __ ] ten
times
we said what's your tone though i
watched the stream ten times the verse
is 10 times and that every time it made
me
write harder and say you know what maybe
i do need to switch up how i'm
performing when i do perform
you know what i mean like he he really
like kiss you mean kiss yeah because
it's like he's showing like
yeah his levels but he's showing like
he's like got everything to the cross
the t's and down your eyes to the top
like on 2k and he's got all the 99s
[ __ ] put the sliders up different type
of [ __ ] man i think that live show is
like you said like plus and it's the
guardian not even that he's prepared and
he ain't rehearses but he's like
he's the one of the creators bro
he's one of them guys
yes man
and i think too like it just showed
everybody
man it's an importance of of
doing [ __ ] because you know this whole
era of music everyone raps over their
track they just rap over there somebody
does yeah yeah and i think they're like
it's been like that for a minute no it
has been certainly in certain aspects
but it also hasn't been what you got
people like met the man no but it's
certain performances you don't do that
on right right and that's the verse and
that's the verses yeah in the garden in
the garden yeah and he's ad-libbing
calling it out yeah like he's he kind of
it's kind of like he
knew they was going to track
right and said i'm gonna expose this
yeah not what everyone knows what it
does no you can't say that i mean i
can't say that though at one point
that's what i thought
that's not what everybody does
everybody do that's not what everybody
does now don't throw new york under the
bus
don't do that
it's not just it's not just god summer
jams are all artists from everywhere to
be fair yeah you show me so i feel like
today
i feel like they thought like if there's
a big venue right like for all this
protocol and i want people to understand
this right that they feel like ah you
know we just going to track it you know
what i'm saying it's the big venue i
want people to hear the the lyrics i
want everybody to hear the song but um
i think
the locks
strategically made it like i
just
they know that protocol be like the two
track so we gonna do it like this so
people could hear us and we and it's
better for our audibles it was calling
but they i feel like portables really
made it like the that was one of their
angles yeah that's definitely
kind of like i think it was like proper
like preparation right
i think like at the end of the day we
know lox
jada chic styles they're all together
always anyway
they ain't like they're like just
kicking it when they got to do remember
[ __ ] they're fans you know what i mean
it was a chemistry party all three of
them was on like sheik was on his [ __ ]
still
style still going crazy yeah for sure
man back to what my brother said he said
listen he said he wished they would have
played certain records just like i wish
the order boot would have been called
when um like when they played the um
their verse from um big pun um you know
the back yeah you know [ __ ] in the
world you know daryl and they're not
being from tv being from tv joint mm-hmm
noise [ __ ] we wish that kim um verse
would have came like oh that's what
y'all want to do let me do mine
let
they know each other's lists so yeah i
was surprised that that's that's what
i'm saying the older boots like if he
would have to use he would have to text
him that would have been the moment if
you've been like you know guys i got a
verse on that song too yeah that's what
it's been like
something like yeah but they surrendered
already i think they had that like he
said strategically they had that plan
like ah they're gonna play this if they
play this that's when you play this if
they play this because they're gonna
play this you play this you know what
i'm saying so that's just like to you
know that might have edged it but dibset
had a great set it's just that people
don't know it just wasn't in the
lockster set exactly it just it went no
no i ain't gonna say it like that said
it went it went
it went on under death is because
strategically they already had it you
know what i'm saying if you play a song
as great as oh boy
you know what i'm saying you know how
great old boy is
it probably won't go after so i don't
know what they play after that but it
like if they play a hard record after
that right it might go with the hard
record oh boy it's not a hard record for
the streets it's a it's a
it's a song that's um billboard flower
i'm saying type [ __ ] jr what what is it
about like you know just your drive and
like like like obviously you've been the
most consistent through the crew just
staying with the with the [ __ ] being
independent building your
building your empire you know you're
involved in the cbd game doing a lot of
[ __ ]
um
but uh what what is it about like the
last decade or so of life that you've
like just doubled down on yourself and
having really you know some at the end
of the day man this rap [ __ ] is always
got to pay the bills it's always got to
make sense it's gotta you know what i
mean like it i'm sure it's easy to get
discouraged like why why did that no i
never get discouraged like even when i
was locked up i always was like
i love rap
i do this [ __ ] every day
so you know what i mean this is you know
this is what i do plus i'm from harlem
so i'm a natural-born hustler so
whatever i could get whatever rap allows
me to get next to and flourish that way
then that's what i do like as far as cbd
or whatever it is
there it is man and uh how many songs do
you guys have all together right now
like oh we got it we gotta we got a lot
you got the whole album we did like we
just did like what four four records
since we've been here we've only been
well
i love la we doing we did we did some
records that i can't wait to people to
hear i'm
they're guaranteed to say yo this is
what we missed
i'm telling you like when you if you're
fans of like
the spitters and you know
i'm not just going to say just dipstick
fans just fans are spitters all right
i think that's why everyone loved you
three because at the end of the day like
i don't think like initially like when
dipset really hit that mixtape run
and i'm not saying like cam is a lyrical
monster right but i think that like
it wasn't as much about the lyrics or
the bars it was more about the the mute
the production the swag the records
and i think when they when they brought
you guys in
it was like oh they just they just
brought through three killers like three
murderers they're like you know what i'm
saying pick up any slack if people were
like yo dip says cool but where the bars
at you know what i'm saying like you
guys delivered that [ __ ] shut up mr zach
my boy mrs zach yeah yeah so yeah no i
mean i'm excited to hear what the uh the
what are you guys calling yourself
just calling ourselves
something
i know i just made that up now it's just
or is it just like individual audience
the group project is just going to be
all three of you guys are primary
artists my new aka is fortune 500 man
i like that
you're making some fortune 500 moves no
obviously if i wasn't rapping i'd be
on a fortune 500 company okay
but yeah
[Laughter]
man we put out the we put out the
upstage that way we just put it under
all of our um playlists basically like
our whole profile right right right as
we we was all main artists it's a great
name for a project to drop the same day
as the dip set project upstage
[Laughter]
let him drop
let him drop i'm just a passenger
what's this one going to be called
oh
the downstage
you know what listen we just we just
playing around
we know we don't have it we don't have a
name we got this record called history
that's crazy though that's coming that
we're going to travel we we're trying to
finish the video
we should call history and um huh
history is that kind of giving
little rundown what's been going on yeah
yeah i mean uh nah not like that can i
break it down yeah go ahead break it
down
well song is called history
and
in the hook i kind of said we made
history
one thing about history you can't write
a real [ __ ] out of history
okay
you understand what i'm saying i
understand what you're saying right so
that right there just speaks for it so
there it is yeah but it's fine you know
you know what we do
no we don't we don't you guys also
working on solo [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i
got uh i really rattled golden shield
on triangle two i got a really rap three
coming out i got my solo album coming i
i'm i got wild records already man i
just think i might do an album together
you know what i'm saying so what about
you [ __ ] we got mad [ __ ] i got um i got
like they keep trying to throw me bags
to do another rap battle because
apparently they like how um
i come in that um that whole field
because um ain't nobody that really like
like at a level of how we rap right a
step into the battle rap arena it's a
whole different there's like very few
people like cassidy did it obviously but
there's only been a few yeah i mean i'm
talking about successfully like do it in
like oh yeah i don't know i'm not i'm
not
and i mean i'm not saying he wasn't
successful enough and i'm just saying
like
i know what i do and people that follow
40 cal know like
it's like it's different it's different
lanes like you could check for me for
what i do with the with the lyrics live
uh
and be like yo damn like look under my
youtube and see like everybody i battle
so you know not about it i feel like
battle rapping is like his own thing it
ain't the same like
this is their nba battle rapping would
be like a dunking contest or the three
yeah contest or something like that
that's a great not everybody contest
they could do that they you know some
[ __ ] to stick to just playing ball you
feel me like like how are we doing the
same it's not good
it's not
but somebody like desmond mason will win
a dunk contest you're like who the [ __ ]
is desmond mason oh no he's a great
dunker oh no but i don't want to look at
it like that i will i will call it like
it's one like and one
rucker park
that's fair that's fair that's like that
yeah what what um when you prepare for a
battle is it like
because obviously you got to kind of do
research on who you're battling right
get some like personal [ __ ] on them like
how like how hard is it to
do that as opposed to i don't know
saying i'm gonna go work on a song
i i'm glad you asked that right shout
out to my um my boy ill right yeah it
was a um when i battled homie his um his
so-called i guess his baby moms
hit me up always the baby moms and i'm
not sure how ill that was right right
like long story short you're gonna take
the information that was like an angle
and that's how battle rappers do
after being in the game i learned that
like you know that's that's like kind of
whack you know and i learned how much a
gentleman he is and how we how after the
battle it just was like we just battled
and we still cool and i seen he just
been on the killing spree since then i'm
like yo so i respect it more so when it
comes to battling it's definitely about
angles and who you um and what you do
but it's like all right let's compare it
more to boxing it's more
jabs is more um how you uppercut
concrete box numbers it's all more of
that than um when it comes to um battle
rap the battleship is disrespectful yeah
like damn how the hell especially when
they go touching [ __ ] hats and
[ __ ] i'm like bro don't touch me bruh
it's not for everybody but yeah no it
could get crazy well look uh do you guys
when you guys dropping the first prize
record from this project oh probably
like sometime next week or two weeks
from now you got to finish the video
yeah we just we shooting a video
probably uh this weekend in miami
yeah so there it is be on the lookout
uh everyone's got music coming maybe a
battle coming from 40 cal
um
yeah and then the group project yeah we
got up stage two yeah upstage two shout
out wrgb
shout out to my people real recognized
bro for the shirt there it is
yo make sure everyone sees this guy's
deal or shirt he's got on fred money
chris chad yo this [ __ ] cost three
thousand dollars b
zoom in on that [ __ ] shirt
hey you always busy hey yo
it's 3 000 if i take it back don't get
mad at me yeah return that [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] there it is baby boom boo lay
calf show